18 mesures d'exposition aux ondes ont
été nécessaires à la municipalité des
clayes-sous-bois pour tenter de rassurer
les habitants
cela fait suite au reportage de
complément d enquête sur l'entreprise
atos et au nombre anormal de cancer rare
du cerveau qui avait créé la polémique
il y a quelques mois nous en avons
réalisés sur des collèges et écoles très
proche d'atos ainsi que sur l'ensemble
du périmètre de la commune dans tous les
quartiers de la commune justement pour
couvrir toute la commune parce qu'il y
avait toujours une inquiétude de la part
des parents qui ont des enfants donc on
a on a souhaité lever 7 1 à cette
inquiétude
et puis après pourquoi en faire sur
d'autres sur d'autres lieux pour balayer
l'ensemble du père l'ensemble du
périmètre de la commune et en plus les
écoles que j'ai cités sont relativement
proches du site d'atos et de des lieux
où il y avait il y avait des antennes
dans le reportage sur le déploiement de
la 5g complément d'enquêté faisait état
de sept cancer au cerveau relevé chez
les salariés d'atos et dix autres cas
aux alentours de plaisir et villepreux
ces mesures réalisées par la ville entre
le 18 février et le 15 mars dernier dans
des secteurs proches d'antennes relais
se sont avérées en dessous des normes
de quoi apaiser le maire des
clayes-sous-bois les résultats des 18
mesure les résultats sont éloquents
puisque si je fais une une moyenne si
tant est qu'une moyenne que puisse avoir
une valeur mais elle a quand même une
certaine valeur
nous arrivons à un peu plus de 0 70
volts par mètre alors que là la
tolérance maximale est de 28 volts par
mètre voyez donc on est très très loin
de la tolérance maxi à l'avenir la
municipalité n'exclut pas vouloir
réaliser de nouvelles mesures d'ici un
an peut-être pour savoir si le taux
d'exposition aux ondes est toujours dans
une norme acceptable